[Musica]
[Risate]
in afghanistan dura da 38 anni e me ne
accorgevo e da bambino quando la mattina
e la sera vedevo le scie di poliestere
che passavano sopra le case
buonasera a tutti e sono ali da cir e
come avete visto sono nato e cresciuto
in in cane sta nella città di casa e
come vedete aveva una famiglia
credo che anche a voi avete una famiglia
be nice però il mio padre abbiamo
studiato giurisprudenza noi era a capo
di un partito un partito militare e
siamo vissute bene come vi dicevo le a
quella in afghanistan dura da una 38
anni da più di 38 anni
[Musica]
io avevo i miei amici camera la mia
famiglia
possiamo far diventare anche una scuola
perché sono tantissimi i bambini in
vacanza non possa
dalla scuola perché mentre camminavo io
sono nato e cresciuto a casini mentre
camminava andavo verso diciamo la città
vedevo spesso vedevo spesso corpi
abbandonati bambini con adulti mutilate
funerario ovunque questa era la
situazione in una stanza io come mi
diceva che una famiglia una famiglia
normale che lui aveva studiato
giurisprudenza della mia mamma anche
sarà in casa abbiamo lavandai ero felice
purtroppo avevo circa 9 anni mentre
quando andava al lavoro e ritornava dal
lavoro veniva sempre accompagnate da
lombarda del corpo mentre un giorno lui
di tornava lavoro io avevo 9 anni
avevano messo una mina per la strada lui
passava in macchina stato saldato stato
ucciso lui stesso a me perché io avevo
tutto tutte quelle che volevo che mi
comprava il giorno dopo meno nell'occhio
mio padre che è successo a me purtroppo
è successo anche la mia mamma è la mia
nonna alla mia sorellina perché noi
siamo andata da festa dalla dalla zia a
casa sono rimaste da mia mamma la mia
donna la mia sorellina loro sono rimaste
a casa perché la mia sorridendo non
stava bene noi siamo andata alla festa
purtroppo che era
ma la festa arrivata una notizia ha
detto che i bombardamenti dei talebani
sono stati uccisi
la mia mamma la mia nonna è la mia
sorellina ci avevo sei anni
io sono rimasto circa un anno in
arkansas che eseguono parlavo con
nessuno un anno data non sono più andato
a scuola trova zia mi diceva ti guarda
che la guerra ancora continua
e successo a tantissimi altri persona in
tantissime altre famiglie perché la
nostra casa è stata distrutta
quindi cosa dovevamo fare allora l'asìa
dietro da guerra continua dobbiamo
scappare dobbiamo andare via
siamo andati via come succede oggi a new
york times e siamo andate via siamo
scappati sono dall'impatto stampa con
sono rimasto due anni andati a una sua
famiglia e la mattina proprio andavano a
scuola una scuola normale con il dg
aiutavo el indio zero perché innaffiare
sono tantissimi rischio rifugiati
afghani in 600mila rifugiati afgani
vivono king il pakistan tra gli ostacoli
sono stato due anni in pakistan
le aziende diceva che perché è troppo
difficile troppo pericoloso e vivere qui
basta doveva scappare devo andare via io
avevo 12 anni
come potevo non abbiamo i documenti e
quindi non potevo salire sull'aereo di
poeta di scender minirampa che devo
andare in iran matera quindi cosa ha
fatto sono andato a parlare con un
traffico
ho pagato un trafficante sono andato con
un trafficante con altre 40 44 persone e
nel viaggio siamo andati a piede cavallo
cambia così via
ci abbiamo messo 28 giorni per andare da
qualità pakistan tino in in iran da
terra era un viaggio lunghissimo che
spesso è in continua lotta tra la vita e
la morte tra lacrime e sangue e spesso
rimane diciamo per tantissimo tempo
senza acqua senza cibo
però devo sopportare perché devo
combattere noi diciamo sopravvivere per
cui stiamo andato impatta de niro
ingrassano rimasti due anni perché io
non volevo venire in europa
io volevo ritornare in afghanistan nel
mio paese tra poco in iran non abbiamo
la possibilità di studiare perché i
rifugiati i ragazzi rifugiati non
possono frequentare una scuola
quindi io io spesso parlavo con
l'azienda saluti
voglio rimanere qui io voglio ritornare
insieme vi sono un po idrico dare
continua però mi hai trovato anche un
numero ha detto che vai verso l'europa
io non sono niente magari ogni tanto
guardava il coraggio magari in qualche
film tra non sapevo nulla e d'italia
nulla e d'italia per cui sono andato a
parlare
un attaccante come succede ancora oggi
oggi la situazione è molto più difficile
e sono andato a darvi un trafficante
dalla soffice c'è scritto uffici
commerciali però mandava le persone
senza documenti
lui che organizzava il viaggio
organizzato da lui mi ha detto io ti
mando fino in turchia fino a istanbul
io non vengo con te io ti mando con
altri trafficanti può darsi che loro ti
chiedono i soldi però se ti che noi i
soldi non devo pagare nessuno
noi siamo un partito dopo una settimana
stanno partita dall'iran terra insomma
arrivata al confine tra i vari tira e la
turchia
per fortuna quando erano in iran
avevo un amico che studiava della
scadenza all'industria dello sport
adatto con lui al telefono mi ha detto
non poi portato tanta cima non riportati
un po di possibilità mila effettivi cuba
che impera tardo quando sono partito
siamo arrivati al confine tra iran e la
turchia
dicevo un trafficante punto che diceva
dovete pagare 150 dollari
noi abbiamo detto noi abbiamo già pagato
perché dobbiamo pagare di nuovo lui a
dettarlo arrivo in un lavoro gratis ci
hanno lasciato
da soli noi siamo rimaste sette giorni
su sette note sulla montagna per fortuna
pochi chili d'uva passare di vitamina ma
gli occhi che di cuba a base di vitamina
ma dopo sette giorni che camminava sulla
montagna un negozio solette sotto scacco
mi faceva male piede in due o più a
camminare
siamo arrivati a siamo arrivate verso
della notte su una montagna i miei amici
mi diceva che non dobbiamo andare il
gioco e la strana perché si vedeva un po
di luce loro pensava che ha forse un
proprio di polizia
io ho detto io non voglio morire qui
sulla montagna io vado io per la strada
loro sono rimasti sulla montagna su un
dato che con la strada quando sono
arrivato nella strada sono arrivate due
candide polizia che mi ringhiava io
vendiamo verso il cane immigrés
sull'alzata così da paura anche carne
avevano paura meter alone di torno e per
fortuna dopo pochi minuti sono arrivate
di due soldati e mi hanno chiesto i
documenti commento raccontata con 18
punti
avevo documento alcun finirà di armi
vendute del documento adesso devo andare
a istanbul solo verona solvendo minuti
mi hanno lasciato andare
poi mi ha notata addirittura anche da
mangiare per bere perché si vedeva dalla
mia faccia con un mangiava da tanto poi
io sono arrivato ad istanbul dei single
sono rimasto tre mente perché abbiamo
tre questa possibilità appena arrivato
in grecia
uno che dovevo come oggi succede quello
che dovevo pagare trafficata perché
pensiamo a madonna c'è questo diciamo
patto tra il governo di erdogan con
l'unione europea sembra diciamo armato
di un adesso non arrivano più non è così
perché non è impossibile arrivare il
viaggio di jeanne è molto più complicata
però si propaghi 4 voglio di più esempio
ad arrivare io ho dovuto pagare 3.500
dollari ad istanbul fino ad atene in
grecia però era diciamo eravamo siamo
rimaste con la nave siamo andati a piedi
ho visto due donne africani che la forza
di andare avanti perché tv voluto
camminare due donne africane 7 pakistan
tre gli inglesi anche noi non avevamo la
forza di portare indietro di un
sopraggiunto sul palco dal successo
perché non avevano la forza di andare
avanti nel ritornare indietro anche noi
abbiamo una forza quindi l'abbiamo
abbiamo versato dei kit poi siamo
arrivati un è arrivato ice grecia in
grecia avevano rubini rendono l'italia
perché volevo andare
avevo tre possibilità aveva tutte le
possibilità di esso esiste solo una
possibilità abbiamo tre personalità
rimane in italia 1 che dovevo pagare a
un trafficante leggera un epoca un campo
loro valore di 500 donne le norme
metteva dentro punti e poi rivendeva in
italia abbondavano bulgaria romania o in
altra parte però un'altra possibilità di
pagare l'autista 1.500 dollari
gli altissimi mette dentro sé quando il
chi entrava nella nave l'autista
rimaneva di o no io non sapevo se levo
fame se cos'è festeggiare la definisce
l'aria ma abbiamo anche un'altra
possibilità che non pagare a nessuno di
venire da solo come succede ancora con
botti e andare sotto un tir di sbagliare
sono semiasse di un tir
diciamo di vedere in in in italia ho
fatto sono subito entrato dentro il
parcheggio sono andata a nascondermi
diciamo sotto il piede sul sembra
chiesti colleghi due ruote le ruote
girano ma se fermo
sono rimasto e due lotti un giorno fine
che è la nave è arrivata venezia io
penso a libri diciamo in un porto
italiano di solito che avevo sentito lo
italiani entrano i loro paesi a tappeto
con mezz'ora si fermano
diciamolo il tiro si ferma io scendo
scappo vado via
e invece purtroppo 13 anni fa l'autista
era un tedesco e io sono rimasto per
quattro ore a venezia fino a bersani il
giorno che aveva tutte acqua mi veniva
infatti migliore sotto tutti e andava il
tiro
e che piangevo parlato nella mia lingua
però non si sentiva a nessuno per
fortuna si è fermato dopo quattro ore
poi sono stata anche fortunata di solito
se invece carico dentro il l'autista al
fra l'asse successo a tantissimi ragazzi
apani ragazzi era piene che non c'era
dentro diciamo carico dell 1 dentro le
lobbies alzato l'asse loro sono state
schiacciate sono morte cosetti però
decreto che vengano dentro il diciamo il
piega che il trafficante ti mette dentro
un che però spesso in porta in caso
qualcosa perché abbiamo visto 22 mette
falla un ragazza a cannes è morto no
anche dentro un tir
io sono elevato in italia sono arrivati
in italia dopo 4 anni e 6 mesi spesso
accade anche oggi dopo diciamo tutti la
mia esperienza sofferta la mia famiglia
eccetera eccetera arrivi in italia
[Musica]
sente che la gente ti definisce il
clandestino ma pensi che chi ma perché
perché perché non è in quel pezzo di
carta in italia in occidente dove
chiamiamo documenti d'identità dove c'è
scritto
non è con un luogo di nascita questo
tool di fronte al 16 nessuno se ti
scuote e respingere o meno all'ora in sé
ma quante sarebbe sfigato che tu sei
nato qua ma chi meritando loro sono
nappi secondo me la virtù umana sarebbe
semplicemente che le persone
amministratori e politici riuscissero
riuscissero a immaginare ascoltare
comprendere queste diciamo questa storia
poi diciamo io lo so lo diciamo non solo
è che io non sono
non faccio parte di nessun partito me ne
frega niente di politica che sia a
destra sinistra però capire prima di
decidere qualcosa di capire chi sono
queste in queste persone oggi in italia
spesso veniamo bombardati dalle notizie
che sono tantissimi persona arrivano
cross tutto sommando quest'anno in
questo evento otto paesi dell'unione
europea sono arrivato 65 mille persone
europa che una partenza diciamo
superpoteri visto il mio nome con
potenza
un forte no mentre se noi andiamo a
vedere siamo quante rifugiate sono in
altre parte come paese più povere libano
niger pakistan e di altri paesi
nel mese prima il video
i rifugiati sono 60 68 milioni di
persone a 68,5 milioni di persone oltre
al giorno secondo dieci anni date delle
nazioni unite 44 1400 persone sono
costrette ad abano abbandonare la loro
casa ad abbandonare la loro casa
poi noi dobbiamo dire diciamo che sono
arrivati a 65 mille in questo 28 paesi
dell'unione europea una invasione
questo è un paese che secondo me questo
è un problema globale noi dobbiamo
cercare abbiamo visto anche nel video
del sito francese che riceve al secondo
longo e nel 2050 arriviamo a 250 milioni
di rifugiati
noi dobbiamo intervenire dobbiamo fare
qualcosa perché non era questo
ovviamente non è un problema diciamo
italia non è un programma europeo un
problema mondiale
dobbiamo trovare una soluzione dobbiamo
trovare una soluzione
questi sono solo oggi sono arrivati in
italia dobbiamo cercarne di un po di
integrarle per il nostro bene ma anche
per benedire
le persone sono 3 per cento dei
rifugiati che sono in europa 3 per cento
io nella mia storia ha fatto un percorso
una vita nuova una vita diciamola reaper
rinascita
questo vuol dire diciamo sin di noi
diamo la possibilità di queste persone
che arrivano possano diventare risorsa
per dovete fare tante cose da fare per
questo vuol dire diciamo dobbiamo
analizzare diciamo dove c'è quale città
serve diciamo operai alle persone centra
eccetera ovvio questo stili tra è una
sfida per noi una visione di sana e
lungo periodo
dobbiamo cercare solo cerchiamo cosa
cosa per questo io diciamo cerco di un
po dell'artista alla mia storia ma è la
storia di tantissimi ragazzi tantissime
persone come me che purtroppo a loro non
hanno la doccia io oggi in italia ho
fatto un percorso
ringrazio anche tante sue persona ma
socialmente l'italia che mi ha fatto
crescere mi ha fatto diventare
oggi sono qui oggi sono qui io ho girato
tanto in italia ho girato abbastanza
l'italia spesso ho visto tantissime
persone veramente fantastici che
bravissime che lavorano per
un'accoglienza per l'italia heartache
per aiutare altre ovvio ricevano neutro
breve diciamo globale o non possiamo
piccolo possiamo risolvere diciamo tutto
il problema del mondo e questo dipende
dalla porzione di sicurezza dell'onu se
forse no però noi del piccolo possiamo
fare qualcosa possiamo fare qualcosa non
possiamo continuare diciamo di non
vedere le stelle in questo problema
queste che diciamo permessi
una sfida quindi viene da noi se siamo
pronte diciamo che siamo pronte ad
affrontare presso cui mi riservo ferma
diciamo una visione di lungo periodo per
poi grazie a tutti
[Applauso]